how many people would I need to get
together to register a small earthquake
of my own hi I'm Tim and this is science
the show where we make science so easy
to understand it couldn't possibly be
accurate it seems like everybody has
World Cup fever and we can't blame this
pandemic on celebrity anti-vaxxers like
Rob Schneider and Jenny McCarthy this
time it's because soccer or football is
so damn exciting during a match between
Mexico and Germany one goal in
particular let so many Mexicans jumping
for joy that seismic sensors picked up a
small earthquake hoon poquito earthquake
oh that got me to wondering how many
people would I need to get together to
register a small earthquake of my own
and I decided to figure it out in an
experiment I like to call shaking things
up with friends before I could get all
my friends together I had to find out
what the hell is an earthquake so I
googled that ship that search led me
down a youtube rabbit hole of vintage
standup clips from a comedian named
earthquake he's really funny Michael he
recommend after that I found out that
earthquakes are usually caused by a
sudden release of energy in the earth's
lithosphere whatever that is reading
that got me sleepy but then I thought
about a hilarious joke earthquake told
on def Comedy Jam in 1995 that woke me
right up hey pals I'm looking for as
many people as possible to meet up so we
can make an earthquake I'll get a case
of beer some chips and dip and more hope
to see you there
and we're off
already got one maybe looks like people
are pretty busy this week maybe some
personal outreach maybe Craigslist will
help
nothing Houston we have some interest
most of these emails are just penises
not very helpful couple of people told
me to eat that's not what this
episode is about but thanks for the
suggestion oh hey are you busy this
weekend do you want to get together for
an experiment I actually had plans this
weekend but thanks
why 14 maybes on Facebook's or five or
six people should show up let's give
this a shot
[Music]
anybody wanna hang out in the park I got
some beers just need to jump around a
little bit it's gonna be it'll be fun
okay
[Music]
so what do we learn today we learned
that people who are your friends on
Facebook aren't actually your friends at
all and sometimes people give you their
phone numbers but they don't want to
talk to you I thought we were learning
about earthquakes yeah well maybe next
time you'll answer my text messages and
we can Greg until then
I'm Tim and this has been science
[Music]